[Music]  [Applause]  hello everyone  it's my pleasure to participate the  annual fgth  conference virtually it's very important  to stay together to exchange ideas  to fresh our minds and promote the fdth  industry development digitalization is  playing a more important role  in our society 21st century is the fiber  century  i perceive a deeper convergence  between the ftth network and the mobile  network in the next  years also the mobile network including  5g  even 60 we're going to rely on the fiber  it's time to accelerate the upgrades  to the fiber network and enlarge the  coverage  in the end i would like to send my  congratulations for the success of this  conference in advance  and hope everybody stay strong stay safe  thank you